[موسيقى]
يمكنني الظهور أمام الرئيس
إنها شركة صغيرة.
مكشوف ، لذلك ليس هذا الشرط
إنه ممتع وكيف يمكنك الفوز
عندما يتعلق الأمر بالتصنيع
كان هناك شاب في ذلك الوقت
ركز على tiktok
[موسيقى]
على أي حال
كيف انضممت لشركتك في كل مرة تضرب فيها؟
ماذا علي أن أفعل؟
يتساءل المزيد والمزيد من الناس عما إذا كنا نقوم بالتجنيد.
علي سبيل المثال
التوجيه والإرشاد والاعتماد هنا
يقولون أن التجنيد قد زاد
نعم
الجانب الذي رأى
لا يمكن أن يحدث هذا النوع من الأشياء هنا في اليابان
سأفكر في الاتجاه المعاكس لذلك الخيال.
أنا صغيرة جدًا لأنني أفعل ذلك متمحورًا حول
جاتوكا
لرئيسي
[موسيقى]
لفعل شيء ما للرئيس
إنشاء المحتوى هو في الأساس
زيادة
[موسيقى]
أتساءل عما إذا كان هناك أي شخص يفعل هذا في اليابان
الآن هذا الإنترنت عبر الهاتف الذكي
ينتشر والعالم متصل
بادئ ذي بدء ، يمكنني إثبات ذلك
كشركة في شكل رائد
أحب أن أكون رائدة في
أنا أفعل الشكل الآن نعم